like in Egypt itself international
opinion is divided over President
Mohamed morsi's ouster numerous
countries have expressed alarm over the
fourths removal of a democratically
elected leader will open it's a basic
right in a democracy for opposition
members to voice their concerns and
stage peaceful protests but it's
unacceptable for a government which has
come to power through democratic
elections to be toppled by the army this
is extremely alarming for the future of
Egypt's democracy dynamic these
neighboring Israel had been keeping a
wary eye on rising religious extremism
in Egypt under Morsi Israel would like
to see the new people the new leadership
in Egypt restoring law and order in
Egypt trying to bring back stability
Palestinian opinion is divided some
sympathized with the opposition while
others saw an ally in Morsy yeah I'm
very upset for him I am truly sad
because he stood with the Palestinians
that look at what he stood firm with us
for the sick patients the products the
diesel and gas moving across borders had
mr. McCallum a government is not the
place for Islamists Islamist groups have
always been isolated or independent to
rule a country and deal with politics is
too difficult for them go bladedge seven
most Middle Eastern governments are
withholding official comment on the
latest developments in Egypt